- I FEEL BADASS!
- YEAH, 'CAUSE WE ARE
BADASS RIGHT NOW!
THIS IS SO BADASS!
- BUT I'VE NEVER DRIVEN BEFORE.
I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN DO IT.
- DERS' LIFE
IS IN OUR HANDS, OKAY?
YOU GOT TO STEP UP
TO THE STREETS, MAN.
LET'S JUST
CATCH UP TO 'EM.
DADDY DEMAMP
WILL TAKE CARE OF THE REST.
- ALL RIGHT.
BUCKLE UP.
WE'RE ABOUT TO GET NUTS.
I GOT DRY-ROASTED, BUT THEY
ONLY HAD CASHEW HAL--HALVES!
YEAH! HA-HA! HA-HA!
I'M DOING IT!
- YEAH!
- HEY, YOU EVER SEE
THAT JAMIE FOXX SPECIAL, UH,
I MIGHT NEED SECURITY?
YOU EVER SEE THAT?
- WHAT DO YOU THINK, DOUG?
- BO-WOW-WOW!
- [laughs]
- "I GOT THE FLAG,
PLAYER, I GOT THE FLAG."
- THERE SHE BLOWS.
- AYE AYE.
[tires screech]
- YO!
THAT'S MY BUDDIES.
- HEY!
- WHERE DID YOU
GET THAT CAR?
CHECK IT OUT!
NO, DON'T!
- DERS SAYS THAT DUDE
IS TRYING TO KILL HIM!
I'M GLAD WE MADE IT HERE
BEFORE HE GOT BLUDGEONED!
- YEAH, WELL, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU GOT UNCLE BLAZER
BEHIND THE WHEEL,
THINGS TEND TO GO
UN-BLUDGEONED!
- HEY, WHAT'S HE DOING?
- I DON'T KNOW!
I'M JAMIE FOXX
AND HE'S TOM CRUISE!
- YEAH!
- GET UP CLOSE!
I'M GONNA SHOOT OUT
THE TIRE!
- YES.
YOU'RE OKAY TO FIRE!
- I'M--
YEAH, I'M GOING TO, OKAY?
IT'S VERY WINDY UP HERE!
- YES, I KNOW!
WE'LL GET SNACKS LATER!
- I GOT--I'M NOT NERVOUS!
DAMN IT!
KEEP IT STEADY
IN HERE, DUDE!
- COME ON, MAN,
I'M A FIRST-TIME DRIVER.
I'M LIKE A STUDENT DRIVER,
BASICALLY.
- YOU'RE DOING
A GREAT JOB, OKAY?
- YEAH, THANKS, MAN.
YOU'RE OUT OF AMMO!
HERE, TAKE THIS!
- OOH, I LIKE THAT.
- ADAM, DERS NEEDS YOU.
HE SAVED YOUR GIRL CATCHER.
- THANKS FOR CALLING IT THAT,
MAN.
[somber music]
♪
[slowed down]
KILL SHOT!
- OKAY, DOWNSHIFT.
- NO!
[both screaming]